الله اكبر اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاح حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله اشهد ان محمد رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد ق الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
[Silence]
شاءك
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
قد افلح المؤمنون الذين هم في صلاتهم
خاشعون والذين هم عن اللغو
معرضون والذين هم للزكاه
فاعلون والذين هم لفروجهم
حافظون الا على ازواجهم او ما ملكت
ايمانهم فان هم غير
ملومين فمن ابتغى
ورا ذلك
فاولئك
هم والذين هم
لانهم وعهدهم
راعون والذين هم على صلواتهم
يحافظون
اولئك هم
الوون
الذين يرثون الفردوس هم فيها
خالدون ولقد خلق الانسان من
سلاله من
طين ثم جعلناه
نطفه في قرار
مكين ثم خلقنا النطفه علقه فخلقنا العلقه
مضغه
فخلقنا المضغه عظاما فكسونا العظام
لحما ثم
انشاناه خلقا اخر فتبارك الله احسن
الخالقين ثم انكم بعد ذلك
لميت ثم انكم يوم القيامه
تبعثون
ولقد خلقنا فوقكم سبع
طرائق وما كنا عن الخلق
غافلين
وانزلنا من
السماء
ماء بقدر
فاسنا في الارض وانا على ذهاب به
لقادرون
فانشا لكم به
جنات من نخيل واعناب لكم فيها فواك كثيره
ومنها
تاكلون
وشجره تخرج من طور
سيناء تنبت بالدهن وص
للاكلين وان لكم في الانعام عبره
نسكم مما في
بطونها ولكم فيها منافع كثيره ومنها
تاكلون وعليها وعلى الفلك
تحون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه
فقال اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره افلا
تتقون فقال الملك الذين
كفروا ما هذا الا بشر مثلكم يريد ان يتفضل
عليكم ولو
شاء الله
لانزل
ملائكه ولو شاء الله لانزل
ملائكه ما سمعنا بهذا في
ابائنا
الاولين ان هو الا رجل به جنه تربصوا به
حتى
حين قال رب انصرني بما
كذبون فنا اليه ان صنع الفلك باعيننا
ووحينا فاذا
جاء امرنا وفارت
النور
فيها
تسلك ل زوجين اثنين واهلك الا من سبق عليه
الول
منهم ولا تخاط بني في الذين ظلموا انهم
مون فاذا استويت انت ومن معك على الفلك
فقل الحمد لله الذي نجانا من القوم
الظالمين وقل رب
انزلني
منزلا مباركا وانت خير
المنزلين ان ذلك
لايات وان كنا لمبتلين
ثمنا من بعدهم قرنا
اخرين فارسلنا فيهم رسولا منهم ان اعبدوا
الله ما لكم من اله غيره فلا
تتقون وقال الملا من قومه الذين كفروا
وكذبوا
بلقاء الاخره واترفناهم في الحياه الدنيا
ما هذا الا
بشر ما هذا الا بشر مثلكم ياكل مما تاكلون
منه ويشرب مما
تشربون ولئن اطعتم بشرا مثلكم انكم اذا
لخاسرون ايعدكم انكم اذا متم وكنتم ترابا
وعظاما
انكم
مخرجون هيهات هيهات لما
توعدون ان هي الا حياتنا الدنيا نموت
ونحيا وما نحن بمبعوث
ان هو الا رجل افترى على الله كذبا وما
نحن له
بمؤمنين قال رب انصرني بما
كذبون قال عما قليل
ليصبحن
نادمين فاخذتهم الصيحه بالحق
فجعلناهم
غثاء فبعد دا للقوم
الظالمين ثم انشانا من بعدهم قرونا
اخرين ما تسبق من امه اجلها وما
يستاخرون ثم ارسلنا رسلنا
تترى كلما
جاء امه رسولها
كذبوه
فاتبعناه
بعضا
وجعلناهم
احاديث فبعدا لقوم لا
يؤمنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر بسم الله
[Silence]
الرحم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
صلا استقيم
واست
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ثم ارسلنا موسى واخاه هارون باياتنا
وسلط
مبين الى فرعون وملاه فاستكبروا وكانوا
قوم
عالين فقالوا انؤمن لبشرين مثلنا وقومهما
لنا
عابدون
فكذبوهما فكانوا من المهل
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب لعلهم
يهتدون وجعلنا ابن
مريم
امه عيناهما الى ربوه ذات قرار
ومعين يا ايها الرسل كلوا من الطيبات
واعملوا صالحا اني بما تعملون عن
وان هذه
امه امه واحده وانا ربكم
فاتقون فتقطعوا امرهم بينهم
دبقا كل حزب بما لديهم
فرحون فذرهم في غمرتهم حتى حين ايحسبون
انما نمدهم به من
بنين نسارع لهم في
الخيرات لا
يشعرون ان الذين هم من خشيه ربهم
مشفقون
هم ربهم
يؤمنون والذين هم بربهم لا
يشركون والذين يؤتون ما ات وقلوبهم هم
وجله انهم الى ربهم
راجعون
اولئك يسارعون في الخيرات وهم لها
سابون ولا نكلف نفسا الا وسعها ولدينا
كتاب ينطق بالحق وهم لا
يسلمون بل قلوبهم في غم من هذا
ولهم بل قلوبهم في غمره من هذا ولهم
اع دون ذلك هم لها
عاملون حتى اذا اخذنا متر فيهم بالعذاب
اذا هم
يجارون لا تجار اليوم
انكم منا لا
تنصرون قد كانت اياتي تتلى عليكم
فكنتم على
اعقابكم
تنكصون مستكبرين به سامرا
تهجرون افلم يدبروا القول ام
جاءهم ما لم يات
اباءهم
الاولين ام لم يعرفوا رسولهم فهم له
منكرون ام يقولون به
جنه الحق واكثرهم للحق
كارهون الحق
اهواءهم لفسدت السماوات والارض ومن
فيهن بل اتيناهم بذكرهم فهم عن ذكر
معرضون ام تسالهم خرجا فخراج ربك خير وهو
خير
الرازقين وانك لتدعوهم الى صراط
مستقيم وان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره عن
الصراط لناكبون
ولو رحمناهم وكشفنا ما بهم من ضر للجوا في
طغيانهم
يعمهون ولقد
اخذناهم بالعذاب فما استكانوا لربهم وما
يتضرعون حتى اذا فتحنا عليهم بابا ذا عذاب
شديد اذا هم فيه مبلسون
وهو الذي انشا لكم الس ع والابصار
والافئده قليلا ما
تشكرون وهو الذي الذي دراكم في الارض
واليه
تحشرون وهو الذي يحيي
ويميت وله اختلاف الليل
والنهار افلا
تعقلون بل قالوا مثلما قال
الاولون قالوا ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا
وعظاما اانا
لمبعوثون لقد وعدنا نحن
وا هذا من قبل ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين قل الارض ومن
فيها ان كنتم
تعلمون سيقولون لله
قل افلا
تذكرون قل من رب السماوات السبع ورب العرش
العظيم سيقولون
لله قل افلا
تتقون قل من بيده ملكوت كل شيء وهو يجير
ولا يجار عليه ان كنتم
تعلمون يقولون
لله قل فانا
تسحرون بل
اتيناهم بالحق وانهم
لكاذبون ما اتخذ الله من ولد وما كان معه
من اله اذا لذهب كل اله بما خلق ولعلى
بعضهم على بعض سبحان الله عما
يصفون عالم الغيب والشهاده فتعالى عما
يشركون قل رب اما تريني ما
يوعدون رب فلا تجعلني في القوم
الظالمين وانا على ان نري كما نعدهم
لقادرون ادفع بالتي هي احسن
السيئه نحن اعلم بما
يصفون سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
ايا نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اعوذ بك من همزات الشياط
واعوذ بك رب ان
يحضرون حتى اذا
جاء احدهم الموت قال ربي
ارجعون لعلي اعمل صالحا فيما تركت كلا
انها كلمه هو
قائلها ومن
ورائهم برزخ الى يوم
يبعثون
فاذا نفخ في الصور فلا انساب بينهم يومئذ
ولا
يتساءلون فمن ثقلت
موازينه فاولئك هم
المفلحون ومن خفت
موازينه فاولئك الذين خسروا انفسهم في
جهنم
خالدون تذبح وجوههم النار وهم فيها
كالحون الم تكن اياتي تتلى عليكم
فكنتم بها
تكذبون قالوا ربنا غلبت علينا شقوتنا وكنا
قوما
ضالين ربنا اخرجنا منها فان
انا
ظالمون قال اخسؤوا فيها ولا
تكلمون انه كان فريق من عبادي يقولون ربنا
امنا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا وانت خير
الراحمين فاتخذتموهم
سخر حتى انسوكم ذكري
وكنت تضحك
اني جزيتهم اليوم بما صبروا انهم هم
الفائزون قال كم لبثتم في الارض عدد سنين
قال يوما او بعض يوم فاسال
العادين قال ان لبثتم الا قليلا لو انكم
كنتم
تعلمون افحسبتم
انما خلقناكم عبثا وانكم الينا لا
ترجعون فتعالى الله الملك الحق لا اله الا
هو رب العرش
الكريم ومن يدع مع الله الها اخر لا برهان
له به فانما حسابه عند ربه انه لا يفلح
الكافرون وقل رب اغفر وارحم وانت خير
الراحمين الله
اكبر الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏break
شاء
[Silence]
‏ist
استقيم
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد ل
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سوره
انزلناها وفرضناها
وانزلنا فيها ايات بينات لعلكم
تذكرون الزانيه والزاني فاجلدوا كل واحد
منهما مئه
جلده ولا تاخذكم بهما رافه في دين الله ان
كنتم تؤمنون بالله واليوم
الاخر وليشهد عذابهما
طائفه من
المؤمنين الزاني لا ينكح الا زانيه او
مشركه
والزانيه لا ينكحها الا زان او مشرك وحرم
ذلك على
المؤمنين والذين يرمون المحصنات ثم لم
ياتوا باربعه
شهداء فاجلدوهم ثمين جلده ولا تقبلوا لهم
شهاده
ابدا واولئك هم
الفاسقون
ان الذين تابوا من بعد ذلك واصلحوا فان
الله غفور
رحيم والذين يرمون ازواجهم ولم يكن لهم
شهداء الا انفسهم فشها احدهم اربع شهادات
بالله انه لمن
الصادقين والخامسه ان لعنه الله عليه ان
كان من
الكاذبين ويدرا عنها العذاب ان تشهد اربع
شهادات بالله انه لمن
الكاذبين
والخامسه ان غضب الله عليها ان كان من
الصادقين ولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته وان
الله تواب
حكيم ان الذين
جاءوا بالافك عصبه منكم
لاوه
شرا بل هو خير لكم لكل امرئ منهم ما اكتسب
من الاثن والذي تولى كبره منهم له عذاب
عظيم لولا اذ سمعتموه ظن المؤمنون
والمؤمنات
بانفسهم خيرا وقالوا هذا
افك لولا
جاءوا عليه باربعه
شهداء فان لم ياتوا
بالشهداء فاولئك عند الله
فاولئك عند الله هم
الكاذبون
ولولا الله عليكم ورحمته في الدنيا
والاخره لمسكم فيما افضتم فيه عذاب عظيم
اذ تلقونه
بالس
وتقولون هكم ما ليس لكم به علم
وتحسبونه
هينا
وتحسبونه هينا وهو عند الله عظيم ولولا اذ
سمعتموه قلم ما يكون لنا ان نتكلم بهذا
سبحانك هذا بهتان عظيم اعظكم الله ان
تعودوا لمثله ابدا ان
كنتم
مؤمنين ويبين الله لكم
الايات والله عليم حكيم ان ان الذين يحبون
انت ان الذين يحبون ان الفاحشه في الذين
امنوا لهم عذاب اليم في الدنيا
والاخره والله يعلم
وان
تعلمون ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته وان
الله رؤوف رحيم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حم الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتبعوا خطوات
الشيطان ومن يتبع خطوات الشيطان فانه يامر
بالفحشاء
والمنكر ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته ما
زكى
منكم ابدا ولكن الله يزكي من
يشاء والله سميع عليم ولا ياتل الفض
منكم والسعه ان يؤتوا اولي القربى
والمساكين
والمهاجرين في سبيل الله وليعفوا
وليصفحوا الا تحبون ان يغفر الله لكم
والله غفور
رحيم ان الذين يرمون المحصنات الغافلات
المؤمنات لعنوا في الدنيا والاخره ولهم
عذاب
عظيم يوم تشهد عليهم السنتهم وايديهم
وارجلهم بما كانوا
يعملون يومئذ يوفيهم الله دينهم الحق
ويعلمون ان الله هو الحق
المبين الخبيثات للخبيثين والخبيثون للخ
والطيبات
للطيبين
والطيبون
للطيبات
اولئك مبرؤون مما
يقولون لهم مغفره ورزق
كريم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تدخلوا بيوتا
غير بيوتكم حتى تستانسوا وت سلموا على
اهلها ذلكم خير لكم لعلكم
تذكرون فان لم تجدوا فيها احدا فلا
تدخلوها حتى يؤذن لكم وان قيل لكم ارجعوا
فارجعوا وازكى لكم والله بما تعملون
عليم ليس عليكم جناح ان تدخلوا بيوتا غير
مسكونه فيها متاع لكم والله يعلم ما تبدون
وما
تكتمون قل للمؤمن قل للمؤمنين يغضوا من
ابصارهم ويحفظوا فروجهم ذلك ازكى لهم ان
الله خبير بما
يصنعون وقل المؤمنات يغضضن من
ابصارهن ويحفظن
فروجهن ولا يبدين
زينتهن الا ما ظهر منها وليضربن
بخمرهن على جيوبهن ولا يبدين
زينتهن الا لبعولتهن او
ابائهن او
اباء ابع
هن او
ابنائهن او ابناء بعولتهن او
اخوانهن او بني
اخواتهن او
نسائهن او ما ملكت
ايمانهن او
التابعين ل الاربه من الرجال او الطفل
الذين لم يظهروا عورات
النساء ولا يضربن بارجلهن
ليعلم ما يخفين من
زينتهن وتوبوا الى الله جميعا ايها
المؤمنون لعلكم
تفلحون
وانكحوا الاياما منكم والصالحين من عبادكم
واماء ان يكونوا
فقراء يغنهم الله من فضله والله واسع عليم
وليستعفف الذين لا يجدون نكاحا حتى يغنيهم
الله من فضله والذين يبتغون الكتاب مما
ملكت ايمانكم فكاتبوهم ان علمتم فيهم
واتوهم من مال الله الذي اتاكم ولا تكرهوا
فتياتكم على
البغاء ان اردنا تحص تبتغوا عرض
الحياه ومن
يكرههن فان الله من بعد
اكراه غفور
رحيم وقد قد انزلنا اليكم ايات
مبينات و مثلا ومثلا من الذين خلوا من
قبلكم وموعظه
للمتقين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
بسم
الله بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولاه و تبع
باحسان ال يوم
الدين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على عبدك محمد
و اله وصحبه
اجمين عليه الصلاه
والسلام عليه اللاسلام
[Silence]
عليه
‏and there and look around now the view
are
‏from even now
cany avilable of the city of
me it
is not
easy if you really in shape 45 bap takes
hours there people do
it the cave
kind out it's kind of ave so to speak
[Silence]
صل
صلى
علم
عليهه عليه الصلاه والسلام ما
بقال
جريل اقرا عليه الصلاه
والسلام
بقارئ
عليه
[Silence]
عل
اقرا بام ربك الذي خلق خلق الانسان من علق
اقرا رب الذي علم علم
[Silence]
الانسان عليه الصلاه والسلام
‏first
[Silence]
عليهه
ضي
[Silence]
عن الله
عليهه
[Silence]
والسلام
عليه
[Silence]
عليهه
‏as
[Silence]
‏days
اله
الاولال الله سبحانه
وتالى لا اله الله محد رسول الله ربنا
اتنا فيدن حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه و عذاب
النار ونا عذاب القبر ونا عبنم ونا
عح ع الجال ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السمي
العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا الرحيم وصلى
الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمين
برحمتك ارحم الرحمين اللهم امين اللهم
امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين استقيم
واعتدل
سوي
الصف الله
اكبر رب الع
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الله نور السماوات
والارض مثل نوره
كمشكاه فيها
مصباح المصباح في
زجاجه الزجاجه كانها كوكب ري يوقد يوقد من
شجره
مباركه
زيتونه زيتونه لا
شرقيه ولا
غربيه يكاد زيتها
يضيء ولو لم تمسسه
نار نور على نور يهدي الله لنوره من
يشاء ويضرب الله الامثال للناس والله بكل
شيء
عليم في بيوت اذن الله ان تر ع ويذكر فيها
اسمه يسبح له فيها بالغدو
والاصال
رجال رجال لا تلهيهم تجاره ولا بيع عن ذكر
الله رجال لا تلهيهم
تجاره ولا بيع عن ذكر الله واقام
الصلاه واقام الصلاه
وايتاء
الزكاه يخافون يوما تتقلب به القلوب
والابصار يخافون يوما تتقلب فيه القلوب
والابصار ليجزيهم الله احسن ما
عملوا
ويزيدهم من فضله الله يرزق من
يشاء بغير
حساب والذين كفروا
بربهم هم
كسراب
بقيعه والذين
كفرهم كسراب بقيعه يحسبه الظمان
ماء حتى اذا
جاء نجده شيئا ووجد الله عنده فوفاه
حسابه حتى اذا
جاءه لم يجده شيئا ووجد الله عنده فوفاه
حسابه والله سريع
الحساب او كظلمات في بحر لجي
يغشاه موج من فوقه
موج من فوقه موج من فوقه
سحاب ظلمات بعضها فوق بعض اذا اخرج يده لم
يكد
يراها ومن لم يجعل الله له نورا فما له من
نور
الم تر ان الله يسبح له من في السماوات
والارض والطير
صافات كل قد علم صلاته
وتسبيحه والله عليم بما
يفعلون ولله ملك السماوات والار
واليه
المصير الم تر ان
الله ولله ملك السماوات والارض الى الله
المصير الم ترى ان
الله ثم يؤلف
بينه ثم يؤلف بينه ثم يجعله ركا
ثم يجعله
ركاما فترى الودق يخرج من خلاله وينزل من
السماء من
جبال
فيها فيها من برد ف به من يشاء ويصرفه عمن
يشاء يكاد سنا برقه يذهب
بالابصار يقلب الله الليل
والنهار ان في
ذلك ل
الابصار والله اخر والله خلق كل
دابه من
ماء
فمنهم
فمنهم من يمشي بطنه ومنهم من يمشي على
رجلين ومنهم من يمشي على رجلين ومنهم من
يمشي على
اربع يخلق
الله ان الله على كل شيء قدير قد
انزلنا
ايات
بنات والله يهدي من
يشاء الى
صراط
مستقيم ويقولون امنا بالله وبالرسول
واطع ثم يتولى فريق من وما اولئك
بالمؤمنين واذا دعوا الى الله ورسوله
ليحكم
بينهم
ويقولون
امنام ويقولون
امنا بالله وبالرسول
واطعنا ثم يتولى فريق منهم من بعد
ذلك وما
اولئك
بالمؤمنين واذا دعوا الى الله ورسوله
ليحكم
بينهم اذا فريق منهم
معرضون وان يكن لهم الحق ياتوا اليه
مذعنين افي قلوبهم مرض ام
تبوه ام يخافون ان يحيف الله عليهم
ورسوله بل
اولئك هم
الظالمون انما كان قول الذين
امنوا انما كان قول المؤمنين اذا دعوا الى
الله اذا ا دعوا الى الله ورسوله ليحكم
بينهم اي ان
يقولوا ان يقولوا
امنا و ان يقولوا سمعنا
واطعنا
واولئك هم
المفلحون ومن يطع الله والرسول ويخشى الله
ومن يطع الله ورسوله ويخشى الله ويتقه
فاول
فاولئك هم
الفائزون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن ال الحمد لله
رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لئن امرتهم
ليخرجن قل لا
تقسموا طاعه
معروفه ان الله
خبير
تعملون قل اطيعوا الله واطيعوا الرسول فان
تولوا فان تولوا فان انما عليه ما حمل
وعليكم ما
حملتم وان تطيعوه
تهتدوا وما على الرسول الا البلاغ المبين
وعد الله
الذين من عملوا الصالحات
ليستخلفنهم
ليستخلفنهم في الارض ض كما استخلف الذين
من قبلهم وليمكنن
لهم دينهم الذي ارتضى لهم وليبدلنهم
من بعد خوفهم
امنا
يعبدونني لا يشركون بي شيئا
ومن كفر بعد ذلك
فاول ائك هم
الفاسقون واقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه
واطيعوا
الرسول واطيعوا الرسول لعلكم
تفلحون يا
اي واطيعوا الرسول لعلكم
ترحمون يا ايها الذين امنوا ليستاذنكم
الذين م كت
ايمانكم لا
تحسبن الذين كفروا معجزين في الارض
وماواهم جهنم ولبئس
المصير يا ايها الذين امنوا ليستاذنكم
الذين ملكت ايمانكم والذين لم يبلغوا
الحلم والذين لم يب غ الحلم منكم ثلاث
مرات ثلاث مرات من قبل صلاه الفجر وحين
تضعون
ثيابكم من
الظهيره وحين تضعون
ثيابكم حين الظهيره ومن بعد صلاه
العشاء ثلاث عورات لكم ليس لكم ليس عل
ولا عليهم جناح
بعدهن طوافون عليكم طوافون عليكم بعضكم
على
بعض كذلك يبين الله لكم الايات والله عليم
حكيم واذا بلغ الاطفال منكم الحلم
فليستن فل استاذنوا كما استاذن الذين من
قبلهم كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته والله
عليم حكيم
والقواعد من
النساء اللاتي لا يرجون
نكاحا فليس
عليهن فليس
عليهن جناح ان يضعن ثياب
ثيابهن غير
متبرجات غير
متبرج
بزينه وان يستعففن خير لهم والله سميع
عليم ليس على الاعمى حرج ولا على الاعرج
حرج ولا على المريض
حرج على
انفسكم حرج حرج ان
تاكلوا ان تاكلوا من بيوتكم او بيوت
ابائكم او بيوت
امهاتكم او بيوت
امتكم او بيوت اخوانكم او بيوت اخواتكم او
بيوت
اعمامكم او بيوت اعمامكم او بيوت
عمكم او بيوت اخوالكم او بيوت
خالاتكم او ما
ملكتم او ما ملكتم مفاتحه او
صديقكم فليس عليكم جناح ان تاكلوا جميعا
او
اشتاتا فاذا دخلتم بيوتا فسلموا على
انفسكم تحيه تحيه من عند الله
مباركه
ط كذلك
يبين لكم
العلكم
تعقلون انما الذين امنوا بال
ورسول
وبالرسول انما الذين امنوا بالله ورسوله
واذا كانوا على امر جامع
معه
انما المؤمنون الذين امنوا بالله
وبرسوله واذا كانوا على امر جامع معه لم
يذهبو لم يذهبوا حتى
يستاذنه ان الذين
يستاذن
اولئك الذين يؤمنون بالله
وبرسوله فاذا فاذا استاذنك فاذن لمن شئت
منهم فاذا نوك لبعض شانهم فاذن لمن لمن
شئت منهم واستغفر لهم
الله
واستغفر واستغفر لهم الله ان الله غفور
رحيم لا تجعلوا
دعاء الرسول بينكم كدعاء بعضكم
بعضا قد يعلم الله الذين
يتسللون منكم
لواذا فليحذر الذي الين يخالفون عن امره
ان تصيبهم فتنه ان تصيبهم فتنه او يصيبهم
عذاب اليم الا ان لله ما في السماوات
والارض قد يعلم ما انتم
عليه ويوم يرجعون اليه
فينبئهم بما كانوا
يعملون
فينبئهم
بما
ان الله بكل شيء
عليم الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
كده الله اكبر
سبحانك
الله بسم الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
الضالين
امين الا ان لله ما في السماوات والارض قد
يعلم ما انتم عليه ويوم يرجعون اليه
فينبئهم بما
عملوا والله بكل شيء
عليم
تب نزل الفرقان على عبده ليكون
للعالمين
نذيرا الذي له السماوات والارض ولم يتخذ
ولدا ولم يكن له
شريك في الملك وخلق كل شيء فقدره
تقديرا واتخ ذوا من دونه الهه لا يخلقون
شيئا وهم
يخلقون ولا يملكون
لانفسهم ضرا ولا نفعا ولا يملكون
موتى ولا
نورا وقال الذين كفروا ان هذا الا افك
افتراه واعانه عليه
قوم
جاءوا ظلما
وزورا
وقالوا اساطير الاولين
اكتتبها فهي تملى عليه بكره
واصيلا قل
انزل الذي يعلم السر في
السماء والارض انه كان غفورا
رحيما قل انزله الذي يعلم السر في
السما قل انزله الذي يعلم السر في
السماوات والارض انه كان غفورا
رحيما وقالوا ما لهذا الرسول ياكل الطعام
ويمشي في
الاسواق لولا انزل عليه ملك فيكون معه
نذيرا او يلقى اليه كنز او تكون له
جنه ياكل منها وقال الظالمون ان تتبعون
الا رجلا
مسحورا
انظر كيف ربوا لك الامثال
فضلوه فضلوا فلا
يستطيعون
سبيلا تبارك الذي ان
شاءء جعل لك خيرا من ذلك
جنات
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار
ويجعل لك
قصورا بل كذبوا
بالساعه
واعتدنا
لمن كذب
بالساعه
سعيرا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حم
ده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم
الضالين
امين تبارك الذي ان شاء جعل لك خيرا من
ذلك
جنات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
ويجعلك
قصورا بل كذبوا
بالساعه وا اعتدنا لمن كذب بالساعه
سعيرا اذا راتهم من
مكان بعيد سمعوا لها تغيظا
وزفيرا واذا القوا منها مكانا
ضيقا
مقرنين دعوا هنالك
ثبورا لا تدعوا اليوم ثب را
واحع ثبورا
كثيرا قل اذلك خير ام جنه الخلد التي وعد
المتقون كانت لهم
جزاء
وبصيرا لهم فيها ما
يشاءون
خالدين انا على ربك
بعدا ويوم يحشرهم وما يعبدون من دون الله
فيقول فيقول
اانتم اضللتم عبادي
هؤلاء ام ضلوا
السبيل قالوا سبحانك ما كان
ينبغي لنا ان نتخذ من دونك من
اولياء ولكن متعتهم
واباءهم حتى نسوا
الذكر وكانوا قوما بورا فقد
كذبوكم بما تقولون فما تستطيعون نصرا فما
تستطيعون
نصرا فما
تستطيعون صرف
ولا نصرا ومن يظلم منكم نذقه عذابا
اليما ومن يظلم منكم نذقه عذابا
كبيرا وما ارسلنا قبلك من المرسلين الا
انهم الا انهم لياكلون الطعام ويمشون في
الاسواق وجعلنا بعضكم لبعض فتنه
اتصبرون وكان
ربك وكان ربك
بصيرا الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
صلاه الوتر ان شاء
الله الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الص عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين
الق قارعه
ومن ادراك ما
القارعه يوم يكون الناس كالفراش
المبثوث وتكون الجبال كالعهن
المنفوش
فاما من ثقل
زينه فهو في عيشه
راضيه
واماما من خفت
موازينه
فامه
هاويه
وما
اد هي نار
حاميه الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليه ولا
الضالين
امين الهاكم
التكاثر حتى زرتم
المقابر كلا سوف
تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف
تعلمون كلا لو تعلمون علم
اليقين
لترون ثم
لترونها عين
اليقين
ثم
لتسالن يومئذ عن
النعيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
قل اعوذ برب
الناس ملك
الناس اله
الناس من شر الوسواس
الخناس الذي يوسوس في صدور
الناس من
الجنه
والناس الله
سمع
الله
حمده اللهم تم نورك فهدي فلك الحمد عظم
حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك اعطيت فلك
الحمد اللهم فلك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه كما تحب وترضاه مل
السماء والارض وملء ما بينهما ومل ما شئت
من شيء
بعد اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا فيمن توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وبارك لنا
فيما اعطيت واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قدرت
وقضيت انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه
لا يذل من والاليت ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك
ربنا نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك اللهم تقبل منا
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وقيامنا
وقراننا وصالح
اعمالنا اللهم تقبل تقبل تقبلها خالصه
لوجهك الكريم برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم انا نسالك الجنه وما قرب
اليها من قول او عمل ونعوذ بك من النار
وما قرب اليها من قول او عمل نسالك من كل
خير سلك منه عبدك ورسولك محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم ونعوذ بك من كل شر استعاذك منه
عبدك ورسولك محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سميع
الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام يا حي يا قيوم عجل بفرجك
اخواننا من المسلمين في كل مكان عجل
بنصرك ومددك يا رب العالمين اللهم فك
كربهم ونفس ونفس
كربهم ونفس ضيقتهم يا رب العالمين اللهم ك
لهم معينا
ونصيرا يا
قوي اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم اجمعين
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏e